مشاهدينا سانتقل الى الزميل هاني صفيان من
ميناء جده حيث وصلت سفينه صينيه تنقل
رعايه صينيين لجده من السودان الصوره مع
كان يتفضل
نعم اهلا بكم مجددا واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا على رصيف من اجل الاسلامي
الواقع غرب السعوديه الان تقف سفينه صينيه
ولكن هذه سفينه سفينه بالاصل هي السفينه
نفطيه ولكن لصعوبه الامر هناك في السودان
فاضطرت هذه السفينه الى اجلاء
مواطنين من الصين او من ابناء جلدتهم على
هذه الحامله وهي حامله نفط يعني هذه من
المفترض ان هذه السفينه هي مخصصه اصلا
للنفط وكانت تقوم بمهمه في نقل اعمال
نفطيه ولكن اضطرت الى حمل عدد من مواطنين
الصينيين واجلائهم وكانت اقرب نقطه لهم هي
ميناء جده الاسلامي يتوقع ان يكون علامتنا
هذه السفينه قرابه 60 شخص من الجنسيه
الصينيه قدموا من بورتو سودان او بورتو
طبعا الان هي تقف على هذه الرصيف او تقف
السفينه على هذا الرصيف وفي استقبالها
الموظفين وكذلك منسوبيه من جده الاسلامي
طبعا هناك
عدد من الجهات الامنيه التي تقوم ايضا
بالاشراف على الوضع الحالي هنا على الرصيف
من منها حرس الحدود وكذلك الجهات الخاصه
بالادارات الصحيه والخدمات الصحيه وكذلك
ايضا يوجد القنصل ايضا والسفير الصيني
وعدد من موظفي السفر الصينيه الذين
يضعونها في هذه اللحظات اللافتات وكذلك
الافتات ترحيبيه وايضا
هي علم الصين لترحيبا
بوصول هؤلاء
المواطنين الصينيين طبعا السعوديه اليوم
او تحديدا نتحدث عن مدينه جده هي اصبحت
اقرب نقطه وتستعين بها دول عديده نتحدث
اليوم عن اكثر من 58 دوله استعنت في
السلطات السعوديه من اجل تسهيل مهمه وصول
مواطنيها الى مدينه جده كون ان مدينه جده
هي الاقرب وهي الامن وايضا هي مناسبه
لوقوف سواء الفرقاطات او ايضا السفن
التجاريه او ايضا حتى السفن النفطيه وكما
هو نشاهد الان في هذه اللحظه وقوف سفينه
نفطيه صينيه هي اصلا في الاصل ومؤده
ومخصصه لحمل النفط طبعا هنا نشاهد ايضا
السفير الصيني وايضا الملحق العسكري في
الصين وايضا بتواجد منسوبين من السفاره
الصينيه هم في استقبال
المواطنين مواطنيهم وكذلك ايضا في اللحظات
التي ننتظر فيها نزول هؤلاء
الصينيون الذين قدموا من
بورتسودان والذين سوف ينزلون في هذه
اللحظات طبعا هناك ايضا من الجهات
الحكوميه
ما قدمته السعوديه ايضا دعما ومسانده
للدول الاخرى التي ترغب بوصول مواطنيها
هنا الى مدينه جده وفرت لهم مقر خاصه
واماكن خاصه وكذلك حافلات اليوم كانت في
ساعات الصباح الاولى كانت هناك اكبر خطه
ايجار واكبر عمليه اجلاء لعدد من رعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه نتحدث عن اكثر من 1670 شخص
من اربعين جنسيه وصلوا الى السعوديه نتحدث
ايضا عن فرقاطه
فرنسيه
والتي تقف لاول مره ايضا على هذا الرصيف
واصلته تحمل على متنها اكثر من 400 شخص
ولكن هم 400 شخص من رايه الامم المتحده او
بعثه الامم المتحده في السودان من خلال ما
واجهوه من هناك من ازمات وخاصه عندما
رصدنا في النشرات السابقه لبعض حالات
الاصابات التي رصدناها وكانت هناك حالتين
اصيبت جراء شظايا من ذخائر وتم نقلهم
مباشره عبر هلال او الاحمر السعودي الى
اقرب المستشفيات التي عدت لهم طبعا في هذه
اللحظات ايضا هناك الجهات حكوميه وامنيه
من قطاعات وزاره الداخليه التي تقوم ايضا
باشراف على سلامه هؤلاء
الواصلين حتى يتاكدون ايضا من سلامتهم
وايضا هناك الجهات الصحيه تتاكد من اي
فروسات
يعني الان سيتم اجلاء هؤلاء الرعايه
واخراجهم من هذه السفينه الى اين سيتم
ارسالهم هل يعني هناك طائرات جاهزه لنقلهم
الى بلادهم ام انهم سيباتون في جده
طبعا بكل تاكيد هناك طائرات خاصه يتم
التنسيق فيها مع الجهات السعوديه مع
السفارات دوالهم وتحديدا سفر الصينيه هناك
طائرات سوف تقلهم مباشره لديهم الخيارين
الخيار الاول اما اقامتهم يمكثون لمده يوم
او يومين وبعد ذلك مغادرتهم الى بلادهم
الى الصين او مغادره مباشره الى الصين
بالترتيبات والتنسيقات مع السفاره الصيني
على كل حال هاني سنعود اليك فورا يعني
بدء اجلاء هؤلاء من من السفينه شكرا لك
نصفيان وراس العربيه حدثتنا من جده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات